[Musique]
une mission suédoise arrive en france
pour cause et avec le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires sociales monsieur le noir
et ses collaborateurs sur le noir que
vous voyez d'ailleurs sur votre écran au
programme de ces conversations
l'évolution de la famille et des
individus il faut dire que les suédois
sont orfèvre en la matière est sans
doute considère-t-on ici en france
qu'ils sont des précurseurs de la
l'intérêt de leurs expériences et même
de leur expérience
l'homme au foyer la non demande en
mariage le congé paternité tous tac
france rock à vue en suède où le bonheur
n'en est pas pour autant garante
on dit souvent que plus la température
est basse dans un pays plus les rapports
humains ils sont chaleureux eh bien
c'est faux allez donc à stockholm vous
en reviendrez déçu la grande suédoise
blonde ne cherche plus laventure comme
dans les magazines
aujourd'hui elle milite pour l'égalité
des sexes à la maison comme l usine et
c'est tout un pays qui se prêtait
l'expérience parlement en tête une femme
sur sept députés ou sénateurs l'école
ensuite où les fils suivent des cours de
bricolage et les garçons des leçons de
couture mais il ne faudrait pas
simplifié l'homme à la maison la femme
au travail
c'est davantage la recherche de nouveaux
rapports entre l'homme et la femme
mariée depuis sept ans à suis doit
secourir
en france j'aurais du mal à donner les
hommes dans les conceptions thema
différente des femmes et que surtout
dans leur façon d'aborder une femme par
exemple fois encore il avoir quand même
selon sa beauté si elle est belle aussi
est facile tout alors que ici vraiment
voilà la femme comme une personne avec
qui on peut parler à conditions égales
dans certains milieux bourgeois les gens
se marient encore mais je crois que la
plupart essaye de vivre ensemble et
quand même essayer de s'en tenir à la
fidélité mais je lève le mariage dans
les conceptions traditionnelles quoi
fixer qu'il ne peut jamais se briser
c'est impensable maintenant l'expérience
passe en effet par une remise en cause
du mariage non pas du couple mais de la
procédure
le concubinage est monnaie courante en
suède dès qu'un couple se forme il le
fait même savoir par le journal local
une autre façon de publier les bans
l'année de la fin de ces sourires en
suède où l'on sait depuis longtemps que
la politique ne réglera jamais les
problèmes du couple et que tout cela
n'est qu'affaire d' équilibre entre
l'homme et la femme
vivre ensemble pour nous c'est que
admettre le l'autre de se développer
livre librement et c'est à dire de ne
pas empêcher l'autre de faire ces choses
dans la vie du hors de la raison est ce
que le couple est en danger en suède
oui on peut dire ça danger pour le
couple certainement car lorsque
l'expérience n'est pas bonne on change
tout simplement
mais déjà on le sent les conceptions
s'inverse on s'est mariés davantage en
suède en 75 174 car plus que le couple
c'est la famille qui courent les plus
graves dangers
la famille est pas important pour nous
le plus important c'est de réaliser
notre propre vie mais est ce n'est pas
en contradiction de se développer
individuellement à travers la famille en
réalité plus qu'à une réactualisation du
rôle féminin
on assiste à une remise en cause du rôle
de l'homme pourquoi l'homme serait-il
différent de la femme
c'est l'histoire et la société
patriarcale qui ont donné cet avantage
les suédois ne sont plus d'accord
l'homme peut pleurer si les tristes
exercé la profession de jardinières
d'enfants sont en route
en vertu de quoi il peut partager avec
sa rame à congé de maternité de sept
mois par exemple
et cela avec l'accord des hommes qui
n'hésitent pas se rassembler en
séminaire pour réfléchir sur l'évolution
de leur conduite d'hommes un homme au
foyer ça ne choque pas en suède
je peux pas dès qu'il ya cinq ans pour
s'endorment qui travaillent s'aggrave
donc n'aurait pas mais ça commence de
plus en plus si c'est la femme qui a les
meilleurs travail c'est elle qui
travaille lui reste avec les enfants
votre rôle vous pourriez très bien le
voir à la maison pourquoi pas est ce que
les hommes sont pas un peu asexué à
s'excuser d'un peu trop fort parce qu
ils sont certainement intéresser des
filles mais l'initiative c'est la fille
qu'il prend qui va vers lui qui essayent
de mai qui prend le premier pas et qui
commence à montrer son intérêt que leur
après bien sûr la réponse parce qu'il
est de l'intérêt là quand même
est ce que je vais dire que les femmes
veulent prendre le rôle des hommes et
vice versa bon c'est une discussion est
très actuelle en suède en ce moment et
les formes il dit maintenant et non nous
voulons pas devenir des hommes l'égalité
des sexes en suède un peu tendance à se
confondre avec une reprise en main de la
société par les femmes l'expérience a le
mérite d'exister mais les bénéficiaires
ne seront probablement pas les suédois
[Musique]